MAX SALTONSTALL: On this
episode of "Stack Chat,"
we welcome Matt Brown,
infrastructure engineer
at Spotify.
Hear how Kubernetes
played a key role
in making the
migration of Spotify's
back-end microservices
as seamless
as possible for the
200-plus teams involved.
Thanks for joining me, Matt.
So why did you choose
Kubernetes over what
I'm sure were many other
alternatives for you?
MATT BROWN: So we've been using
containers for a long time,
since about 2013, since
Docker was very new.
We had built our own
container orchestration system
around 2013, before there really
was other choices out there.
And we named it Helios.
And we open-sourced
it, coincidentally,
the day before
Kubernetes was announced.
So we didn't really
know at the time
that there was something
else coming that we'd use.
And so we knew, I
think, for a long time,
we didn't want to continue to
be in the business of building
our own orchestration platform.
Kubernetes is a wonderful
open-source project--
a huge amount of
contributors, great velocity.
And so we knew eventually
we wanted to move over to it
just to get a lot more features,
and impact from the community.
And we think, in the end, the
orchestration platform that
will have, this
thing, the offering
we can make to our
own engineering team,
is going to be so
much better if we
can be a part of this big
open-source movement instead
of having a team of
four or five engineers
building our own
thing internally.
We thought it would take--
or at least I
thought initially--
we'd have to do a
lot of selling, kind
of talking, nudging people
along, pushing people along,
at some point.
But we found that
most teams were pretty
motivated to adopt Kubernetes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So
how did you approach
doing this transition from
your custom-made orchestration
to GKE over time?
MATT BROWN: A big principle we
had for trying to figure out,
how are we going to move
over, was trying to--
we really wanted to make the
migration for each engineering
team at Spotify as
easy as possible.
But we feared if we had to
teach every team, times 200
or so teams, how do
I use Kubernetes,
or if it was a completely
different system from what
they use today--
different metric
systems, different ways
to do logging, et cetera--
or if the two systems
couldn't talk to each other,
then the migration project
would be never-ending.
Because Spotify's
back-end is organized
into hundreds of
thousands of microservices
from different teams
talking to each other.
And so one thing we really were
afraid of and wanted to avoid
was, in order for my team to
move my service to Kubernetes,
I need to organize with the
other teams calling my service,
and we all have to move
it at the same time.
That would have led to
a ton of dependencies,
and would have taken many, many
years to move one service over,
let alone 1,000.
We had built a system on top
of Helios that we call Tugboat.
And it really just gives a
simpler interface and API.
And we realized,
well, we already
have almost every service at
Spotify talking to this API.
And basically, they can just
say, they can tell Tugboat--
I have a new version
of my service.
Please go deploy it
out to the world.
And it gives a much
simpler interface.
Helios was a little
bit low-level.
And so we realized,
well, if we just
add Kubernetes as another
option to this system,
we already have everything
integrated with it.
If we wanted to find a new
next-generation deployment
platform, for example,
we'd have to do
all the work of
integrating everybody
with it all over again.
So we just basically added
Kubernetes as another option
to Tugboat.
MAX SALTONSTALL: How did
you weigh the pros and cons
of Kubernetes with your own
management versus managed GKE
deployment?
MATT BROWN: So over the years,
as we were trying to think,
when is a good time to start
seriously adopting Kubernetes--
and we did want to
wait for a while,
because Helios helped
us make great strides,
and it seemed like Kubernetes
was still kind of growing,
still figuring a lot of things
out, just like any project--
as we were doing that
and kind of waiting
for when is the right time, we
were moving our whole back-end
to Google Cloud anyway, and
getting rid of our own data
centers.
So there wasn't really much of
an argument to be had to say,
like, we want to build
our own clusters,
learn how to do all
of the networking,
do all the stuff
ourselves the hard way.
One of our main
motivations for adopting
Google Cloud in general
was just to take advantage
of many managed services,
and so our teams
can kind of focus
on upper layers
and spend less time
on lower-level things.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So then
with all these services,
how do you make sure
that, as they're shifting,
they can still collect
metrics and understand
their context within that
Spotify microservices
ecosystem?
MATT BROWN: We did a lot of
work as an infrastructure team
to make sure that if your
team is building a container,
the things that you would
see in the environment
in our old system
in Helios would look
mostly the same in Kubernetes.
And that's things
like, service discovery
would be handled for you.
That was one of the
features of Helios.
Metrics were provided
by just a process
running on a known port on the
same machine as your container.
So you could just
send metrics to that.
And we had similar things
for secrets and logging.
So we did a lot of
work to make sure
that all of that looked the
same in Kubernetes, so that you,
as an application, or what
we call a feature team,
really didn't have to
rewrite your code at all.
You can just take
your container,
which is already packaged
up, and move it to the new--
move it to Kubernetes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you
enjoyed this episode,
check out the "Stack Chat"
playlist for more videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]